le tennis avant vous c'était très coincé
non
c'était différent
de jouer au tennis à cause de vous en
vous regardant en gardant les gens comme
vous des gens comme Smith Connor pasta
et à partir de lundi linastase vous êtes
donc jusqu'au 8 juin jusqu'à vendredi
prochain donc vous participez à Roland
Garros au Trophée des légendes et Dieu
sait si vous êtes une légende les gens
c'est pas je suis un petit peu ancien on
dit mais
c'est pas mort encore mais bon
alors vous retournez sur les cours après
une carrière exceptionnelle et une
tentative de reconversion en politique
dans votre pays d'origine qui est la
Roumanie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 19 juillet 46 le même jour que Bill
Clinton est-ce que cet amour des femmes
que vous avez qui l'a est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est j'utilise pas le
cigales
alors vous êtes né à Bucarest en
Roumanie donc dans une famille modeste
votre père s'occupait de l'entretien du
stade de Bucarest où on faisait à la
fois du foot et du tennis et j'ai dans
ce stade que quelques années plus tard
vous jouerez la Coupe Davis mais quand
vous aviez trois quatre ans vous étiez
cachés dans les tribunes tout nues et on
faisait pipi sur les gens
je savais pas comment on joue avec les
balles de tennis regarder seulement les
tennis tout nu et de temps en temps
j'avais envie de faire le pipi sur les
gens
alors c'est une époque assez difficile
en Roumanie parce que c'était après la
guerre une grande famille en Roumanie
après après la guerre et alors il y
avait des on élevé des vaches et on
élevé des chèvres sur le stade de
Bucarest et c'est pour ça qu'on a dit
vous étiez un fils de berger en fait
parce que non mais c'était le seul moyen
que on pouvait manger quelque chose
alors quand j'étais petit vous aimiez
pas trop l'école vous préfériez frapper
frapper des balles déjà avec une
raquette en bois à côté de chez vous il
y avait une usine de chocolat et vous
frappiez les balles comme ça contre
l'usine de chocolat et les ouvrières ils
étaient par là il faisait rire alors les
ouvrières elles lui balancer des
chocolats ça va pas changer finalement
vous avez fait ça toute votre vie après
sauf qu'après c'est des dollars quand
vous jetez
aussi c'est bon aussi
alors à 12 ans vous êtes déjà parmi les
meilleurs tennismens roumain et en 62
donc vous remportez le championnat de
Roumanie et puis à 16 ans vous vous
retrouvez face à un grand joueur qui
était cinquième joueur européen à
l'époque s'appelle le Yann tillac
vous gagnez le premier set et il vous
dit c'est comme ça que tu espères gagner
pauvre con j'ai la même chose c'est toi
qui est un con mais oui
c'était petit mais j'avais l'envie de le
battre
c'est le début d'une grande amitié ça
commence toujours
en 64 vous vous lancez dans le circuit
international avec lui à l'âge de 18 ans
mais alors comme la Fédération roumaine
vous donne 2 dollars par jour c'était
vraiment pas beaucoup que de défraiement
à l'époque on se devriez bien à Paris je
me rappelle port de thé on était nos
portes
et on partageait une chambre pour 10
francs en 66 vous êtes obligé de vendre
les les raquettes les enfin tout
l'équipement qui vous est donné par les
vos chaussures qui étaient faites dans
des pneus découpés elle glissait
un chaussette et je gagnais comment tu
sais j'étais là il est toujours gagné
pas toujours non 73 il a gagné à Roland
Garros en tous les cas vous arrivez au
sommet du tennis mondial à un moment
faut dire aussi où la télévision a
commencé à retransmettre les matchs
le premier à faire rire les gens à faire
de l'humour du spectacle sur les cours
non aussi non je l'ai fait pour moi
toute façon et si les gens aiment ce que
je fais sur les courses encore mieux
mais je l'ai fait pour moi mais c'est
vrai que le tennis avant vous c'était
très coincé non
un jour vous jouez en Écosse vous jouez
en kilt à Berlin il y avait un jouet
contre un tennisman qui avait l'habitude
de mettre des coups de poing à tout le
monde vous arrivez avec des gants de
boxe vous jouez un jour avec un
parapluie parce qu'il pleuvait
à Londres un jour il y a votre frange
qui vous gêne vous empruntez des ciseaux
à quelqu'un qui est là vous coupez la
frange sur le court et le plus drôle je
trouve c'est qu'un jour vous jouez en
double avec Arthur H et vous passez le
visage au bout de noix pour être noir
tous les deux c'était à l'époque on
devait avoir la même couleur
d'équipement et je me suis dit
il y a un mec qui parlait sans arrêt
derrière vous comme ça et vous vous
retournez vous dites ta gueule et
c'était le duc de Cannes quoi et quand
je me retourne je vois c'est
le cousin de la reine et quand j'ai
réalisé que c'était lui je suis tombé
dans mon genou je dis plus chadap
[Rires]
vous dites illinestas faire le con c'est
ma façon de me concentrer c'est vrai je
pense c'est pas seulement c'est le cas
de maquereau aussi quand on fait le
compte sans façon de concentrer pour moi
de toute façon
vous êtes aussi grand seigneur parce que
par exemple vous avez laissé gagner Tom
Gorman qui était en fin de carrière vous
l'aviez déjà battu 11 fois
et son dernier match vous le laissez
gagner c'est sport oui je sais pas si
c'est mais je le fais génial vous avez
vraiment
et tout d'un coup je vois une balle qui
passait derrière lui quand il servait je
faisais pas attention pendant 5-7 5e 7
je regarde chaque fois qu'il se réveille
une balle la deuxième elle lâché
derrière j'ai pas fait attention pendant
5 7 et je suis allé le dire est-ce que
ta maman est à Paris que tu dois garder
la poche
alors le 23 août 73 donc quelques
semaines après votre victoire à
Roland-Garros vous êtes premier numéro 1
au premier classement ATP puisque ça a
commencé cette année-là et vous restez
premier pendant 40 semaines au total
vous avez remporté 57 tournois ATP et
puis voilà en 85 vous dites voilà ma vie
en tant que tennisman c'est un peu fini
et vous voulez une autre vie une vie
plus calme vous dites c'est ma vie qui
commence maintenant il faut que je
m'habitue à être une personne comme les
autres à avoir une existence normale
vous vous reconvertissez dans les
affaires avec Yoann thiriac il est
devenu très riche mais il était devenu
milliardaire
alors là bon ben vous faites des
affaires avec Tiriac et alors donc quand
la cinquantaine arrive lassez un petit
peu elinastase vous vous dites
finalement il faudrait que je fasse
quelque chose de constructif et vous
vous lancez dans la politique
annoncé les rues étaient des Français et
puis Nastase dit c'est dommage et tout
ils sont copain lui dit finalement tu
t'appelles Eli Nastase occupe-toi de ta
ville et là vous présentez aux
municipales à Bucarest campagne assez
populaire c'est voir populiste d'une
certaine façon
vous allez partout allez comme ton
amicher les usines les ateliers les
cours d'école les jardins publics le cul
des vaches
votre cote a grimpé très très vite hein
non je pense que j'ai représenté un
parti qui était pas très populaire à
l'époque c'était les parties du
gouvernements maintenant il est au
pouvoir de nouveau mais à cette époque
là c'était pas le bon moment on a dit
aussi vous aviez eu des avantages à
l'époque de tiuscu
l'avantage c'était que ils m'ont laissé
jouer au tennis et faire un petit peu
d'argent ils m'ont laissé faire ce que
j'avais envie c'est pas des avantages
d'avoir serré la main d'avoir reçu une
médaille de lui serait la main une fois
j'étais obligé de serrer la main c'était
pas parce que je voulais seulement vous
dites de toute façon quand on a de la
famille dans un pays comme la Roumanie à
l'époque on est obligé d'être communiste
d'une certaine façon parce qu'on a peur
j'avais peur pour la famille pas pour
moi parce que je pense un jour il me
disait tu dois nous donner l'argent tu
peux pas sortir la prochaine je partais
je revenais plus mais ils m'ont jamais
dit ça donc vous vous sentez un peu
coupable aujourd'hui de votre attitude
pendant que non je pense que je tout
seul je pouvais rien faire de toute
façon
très fort pour alors on vous a attaqué à
cette époque-là même sur votre vie
privée on a même dit que vous étiez
homosexuel
ce qui est beaucoup plus
alors résultat donc effectivement 43%
pour Eline astase et 57% pour votre
adversaire et là vous retournez vers le
tennis quoi un peu déçu de cette
expérience
c'était une expérience que il y en avoir
avec le sport le sport on gagne européen
mais là-bas il faut faire des
concessions et tout ça je pouvais pas
faire ça mais c'était intéressant au
début à la fin non donc là vous revenez
vers les tournois pourtant vous avez pas
besoin d'argent non je suis président de
la Fédération depuis quatre ans
j'aimerais faire un grand centre de
tennis en Roumanie c'est mon projet avec
mon argent le gouvernement ils m'ont
donné un terrain pas très très bon dans
le milieu de la ville et puis je suis
très à l'aise dans le tennis j'ai pas
besoin d'argent mais j'aime bien rester
en contact avec le tennis
j'aime bien même regarder les juniors je
vais dans tous les cours
ça dépend
une maison en appartement à Paris à New
York une amie une à Monte-Carlo tu as
quoi comme pompe
non
parce que sinon on a une combine pour
les pompes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être vous savez pas combien vous
avez d'argent mais vous savez pas non
plus combien vous avez une femme parce
que vous êtes un grand séducteur et vous
allez nous donner des conseils on va
faire l'interview alerte rose
[Musique]
est-ce que vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer
vous préférez larguer ou faire larguer
vous êtes un sentimental
vous préférez embrasser vous faire
embrasser
caresser ou faire caresser
quel est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour sur un cours de tennis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de chez Renault des années 60 pour
Christine c'est voilà non mais c'est ça
qui est drôle mais c'est bien moi
absolument est-ce que vous avez besoin
de faire l'amour pour aimer ou d'aimer
pour faire l'amour
c'est dur ça
préfère quoi
alors oui est-ce que vous préférez une
femme qui baise bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui baise mal mais
qui est fidèle
bon une qui baise bien voilà même si
elle est infidèle
oui vous pensez qu'avec vous elle va
rester fidèle de toute façon ah oui
c'est ça
et vous Christophe je pense pas jouer la
grande fidèle mais bon je pense que je
m'en fous
alors vous préférez qu'elle vous quitte
enfin vous préféreriez qu'elle vous
quitte pour un homme ou pour une femme
et si vous préférez être caressé par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne
on va trouver ça ou battue
vous aime
bah tu peux quelqu'un quand même
vous préférez que votre femme votre
fiancée couche avec un autre en pensant
à vous ou couche avec vous en pensant à
un autre
ça fait du mal ça hein
[Rires]
et vous Christine a une autre en
consomme
il faut tout se dire ou rien savoir
cette question si tu dis tout est dans
la merde ça c'est sûr
est-ce que pour vous embrasser c'est
tromper
[Applaudissements]
c'est une négociation
là on arrive à la question importante
dites question Michel Rocard et je me
suis fait épingler par Laure Adler qu'on
a connu beaucoup moins puritaine et une
certaine époque au sujet de cette
question
Laure elle a dit que Thierry Ardisson
demandait cette question là et que c'est
la choqué on l'a connu moins choquée il
aura de l'air bien alors
regardez-moi bien l'inastase est-ce que
sucer c'est tromper
je sais pas je parle pas bien français
s'il vous plaît
en fait c'est le mot trompé qu'il a pas
compris
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu